his rookie year I knew he's a baller
because he was letting our sideline know
how much money yeah thank you already he
was letting us know he was the man cuz
he's top-10 pick right would you go
eight yeah woody I was draft that small
only here the draft and rather draft was
amazing man yeah two thousand four
thousand four and that was back when you
know they only took about to the top
five guys you know I'm in the room with
guys like Eli Manning who's supposed to
be number one overall Big Ben and Robin
gallery and I'm like dude I don't care
if I sit in that green room and I'm the
last one I want to share in this
experience and you know we had a running
joke like who's gonna be the last guy
drafted and you know I wasn't upset I
said I'm gonna be the last one I know
I'm going ten in Houston so everyone
kind of has their on the table when you
haven't been drafted you're sitting back
watching this unfold right and so yeah
we Eli San Diego drafts instance where
they actually figure out the tree we
literally sat back and watched him not
want to hold the jersey not wanna put
the head on he's just in there yes and
so as the drafts kind of going on guys
are getting called guys are getting
called me and Ben or less and I'm just
thinking you know and I had actually
went to the bathroom and then I heard my
name eight and you know as I'm hugging
my mom and kissing her and dapping up my
brothers and stuff I just kind of look
over at Ben and like I guess you'll a
you know a running joke that's awesome
he probably went in the best spot
because he has two rings he went to a
great defense great organization and so
everything happens for a reason but I
was not the last one even though all
week long that's all we joked about